i feel like i'm probably stronger in
three plus two
or um three oh just because of the
like my ability to dirty flag but
um this will be it's just higher quality
chess
three plus two whoa cynical mustard
thanks for sharing the love gifting 10
subs
not sure if i recognize that name i
appreciate it
okay stafford gambit time gambit
accepted um
so i might get a bad position from the
opening but
at the very least i should get a time
advantage i'm happy to see bishop e3
this is actually a fun line queen f3
queen g5
so i'm hitting e3 there's a cool trap in
this variation
at queen f4 the trap is after king d2
there is knight h2
and um
i'll have to show it after the game it's
a line i trap nemo in
at some point
h4 looks suspicious
h6 was uh was the last movement my prep
wondering if i can just play queen c5
i guess then there's king d2 but then
this move
okay it's getting interesting so i think
i'm guaranteed to win
back the pawn even though okay c7 is
hanging but
i don't think white wants to take that
question is why you awake d oh that's a
good question
not entirely sure of the answer also i'm
probably gonna lose the c7 pawn after
rook b1
or that move
yeah this
okay let's try and make this work
very soon i can castle like the fact
that i've committed to h5 it shouldn't
be
too damaging
but i'm probably not probably worse here
because white can just take
oh but if takes i have i might have
knight e3
but not right away because queen e5
helps defend and check
so if takes i probably just castle and
try and laugh at white's king in the
center
yeah i'm awake because i'm not asleep
ah
um how many ponds do i want to lose
if i take here i'm losing b7 and
[Music]
probably eventually c6 too
the thing is if i take with this pawn
then this
push could be scary
but i should probably take this way
and if the pawn pushes i
play g6 king h7
try and survive
okay white just wants to trap my queen
this is now a massive threat
so i have to i probably have to trade
queens
i'm down the pawn but there is there's a
weakness on
oh there's weakness on b6
okay let's complete development probably
eventually play this move
ah white's doubling though but i have
this now
the only move i saw there
yeah so we're gonna trade
do i keep pushing i guess i do
at some point i might want to play g3
even though okay there's knight e2
maybe not
you just double up behind the pawn
it's my baby i have to protect it
c4 could be coming
and knight f4 or knight d4
uh what to do
i feel like i should play c5
rook c7
[Music]
there's also f5
i mean in order to like win this game
i'm gonna have to be tricky
even to draw the game
i have to pull some tricks out of the
hat
yeah really not clear what to do
i think i'll play f6 just give the
bishop a square
i really don't want to go zero out of
two for the first two games of the
stream
but it might happen okay setting up at
least so
simple thing
[Music]
now what to do you work here
eventual ideas to swing over
the white's so solid though
bishop here i do f5
time is dwindling
have to live on the increment
and defend the pawn
i play f5 now probably not
okay rooks are just defending everything
oh there's a cool idea to play this this
and this
okay not going to work though whoa it's
a raid
just guy thanks for raiding
if you're just joining i'm in deep deep
trouble
[Music]
trying to knock flag and not lose
but it's going to be tough
i'm threatening this but there's just
takes
okay so i'm down how many ponds am i
down i'm down two pawns
but white has no past pawns
except about to have past pawns
i just want counter play all i want to
do is attack the
g-pawn
this is something c5 and then i can come
around
here i take
ah
no
okay there is one trick
one trick
is it drawing it might be
it might be drawing
i just check i continually check the
king
the king ever moves here i win the rook
i i'm gonna draw this oh it's a miracle
wow this is why you don't resign
children and adults that's a beautiful
stalemate too
a double pawns
if it takes it's just stalemate
let's go good evening from singapore
nice draw oh thank you
wow that's such a weird
idea i kind of saw it coming
like here i saw i saw the fact that the
king is limited on squares
but it took a moment to realize that the
like the king has no escape
because even if it moves like this way i
just keep checking and the pawn controls
kind of the getaway squares that was
really nice
i mean i i was suffering the whole game
it was just a long period of
sadness uh something went wrong from the
opening
but it's nice to i guess have a game
like this where
i can hopefully learn from the opening
and um
improve next time and
and still not lose the rating points i
gained two points because my opponent
was
almost 100 points higher rated than me
yeah this computer graph
i kind of feel for my opponent though
like it's tough when you work so hard
to like try and convert a winning
position and then
don't quite make it so that was probably
youtube worthy
but real quick for people watching in
the future on youtube
and in the present on twitch i do want
to show kind of the main trap
from this line um
[Music]
because bishop e3 it's kind of um it's
intended to be a safer move from white
but after yeah after knight g4 black
already has initiative
queen f3 and if we look this up in
licha's database queen g5
most played move is king d2
and then there's a really cool move from
black um
the third most popular is knight h2
and the idea it's actually interesting
most people take
so most people playing white will not
see the idea coming
but after rook takes h2 queen e5 will
win a rook by force because queen b2
will trap this rook
and that's just winning material here
um so i think i had this like once on
stream against nemo
in our match from a few months ago
um but it's one of the like cool traps
in the staffer in which
i mean this line isn't the most common
but i guess if they play bishop e3
then like these moves are natural for
white to play
so queen f4 is the best move here
preventing me from winning the pawn
because my queen's hanging it takes a
pawn undoubles
so h6 was a a prepared move
i remember actually discovering this
move when i was preparing for nemo
and the idea is i just defend my queen
and now i'm threatening to take the pawn
because my queen still attacks through
x-ray vision
and if whites to take here then i take
back and the pawns are now forked
because each file is open
so h4 was the first kind of new move for
me
and i guess this is just better for
white according to the engine
uh i thought i was going to win back a
pawn but
yeah white played i played the right
moves
and this is already just bad for me so
if i get this again
uh queen b5 is actually kind of
it's like a weird engine move because
queen c5 looks so much more natural
but here i hit the pawn
[Music]
and and yeah the king stays on e1 the
king's actually
it's better to leave on e1 because here
the knight wouldn't be defended
and b3 i guess provoked some weakness
and okay this would be playable
eventually h5
and then down the pawn but the king
doesn't have a clear safe place to go
so anyway uh if that goes on youtube
i i've had a good share of like youtube
content
where it's like never give up hope never
resign
like executing these dirty stalemate
traps
so this is another one to add to the
collection
but it's um it's a really important kind
of
i guess concept to know and understand
is that when you're in a losing position
like in this case down sony pawns and
end game
usually you want to keep keep a rook on
the board
so if your king winds up in a stalemate
position
then sometimes there's opportunities to
to sack the rook by force and this is
what we call crazy rook
or mad rook where um
yeah you just keep checking the king and
if the king were to move
all the way here white would have to
take
because otherwise 24 hours sleep cycle
oh uh i could try
but i think first first before that
i'll end the youtube video so people
watching in the future on youtube
if you made it this far uh leave a
smiley face
in the comments and like the video and
watch on twitch if you want to watch
things like this in real time
oh and smiley faces in the twitch chat
too
twitch chat is so happy right now look
at twitch chat
they're so happy
nice to see that makes me happy
do i just make the youtube video like
five minutes longer than it needs to be
just being fascinated by
the the smileys in twitch chat